der Flirt mit der Kamera gelingt ihm
fast immer Robert Habeck in Bayern der
Minister besucht ein Unternehmen das
Türme für Windräder herstellt habe
gefühlt Habeck schaut habe ich staunt
Wirtschaft mag im hier und da noch fremd
sein schöne Worte findet er trotzdem
einfach mal so ein Turm anzufassen zu
sehen wie groß der ist sich klar zu
machen dass der produziert werden muss
dass hier Menschen sind dass es Energie
braucht das ist Rohstoffe braucht also
die Herausforderung in der Tiefe einmal
zu sehen das prägt einen natürlich kein
anderer kann Soko ketch staunen über die
Tragweite der eigenen Aufgabe
wir haben hier gebaut bevor Sie eine
Unterschrift von mir hatten ob
schwimmende lng-terminals auch für das
lang verheistete Fracking Gas aus
Amerika ob kutao in Katar nichts bleibt
Leben was die Menschen in Robert habe
gesehen ist glaube ich ein Politiker und
ein Menschen der reflektiert und der
quasi während wir zuschauen nachdenkt
und zum Teil eben auch wirklich in dem
Prozess selbst zu anderen Schlüssel
kommt oder zu neuen Ergebnissen kommt
aber die Menschen eben daran teilhaben
lässt das aber nutzt sich ab findet
zumindest die Opposition ich bin ehrlich
ein bisschen enttäuscht von Robert habe
ich am Anfang dachte ich dass wir da
wirklich mit mit Offenheit und
Pragmatismus arbeitet und er sozusagen
die klassisch grüne Vergangenheit etwas
nach hinten anstellt im Moment ist genau
das Gegenteil der Fall er steckt mitten
in seiner grünen ideologischen Blase
im Ministerium agieren andere Sven
Giegold etwa Habeck Staatssekretär gut
vernetzt bei kapitalismuskritischen NGOs
gilt als graue Eminenz hinter dem grünen
Wirtschaftsminister Wachstum wird neue
definiert ebenso die Zielmarken für
Wohlstand statt klassischer
Wirtschaftsindikatoren nun grüne
Maßstäbe Ökonomen sehen das kritisch
um das in Maße zu übersetzen rate ich
dazu ein bewährten Maßen festzuhalten
wie beispielsweise den
Bruttoinlandsprodukt der
Arbeitslosigkeit der Inflation weil wir
da schon genau wissen in welcher
Hinsicht sie manipulierbar sind und in
welcher nicht besonders scharf zeigt
sich dieser Kontrast in der
Energiepolitik nicht nur der Krieg in
der Ukraine treibt die Preise auch
ehrgeizige Ausstiegspläne die den Strom
verknappen viele Unternehmen etwa die
BASF ziehen Konsequenzen der größte
Chemie-Konzern der Welt seit 150 Jahren
in Ludwigshafen zieht sich schrittweise
aus Deutschland zurück investiert den
anderen Märkte wenn Deutschland nur noch
das Auslaufmodell ist wo ich zwar
bestehende Fabriken solange sie noch
funktionieren betreibe aber die neue
Investition außerhalb Deutschlands
passieren dann haben wir für den
Standort nichts Gutes getan und für
unsere gesamte Gesellschaft auch nicht
besonders dramatisch dann wenn es
Zukunftsbranchen betrifft wir haben das
bei der Chip Industrie gesehen wir haben
das bei der Solarindustrie bei der
Batterieproduktion gesehen und es ist
wahnsinnig anstrengend diese dann wieder
zurückzuführen das geht nur mit
wahnsinnig viel Geld und dafür muss dann
die Gesellschaft wieder aufkommen eine
einseitige Festlegung auf Strom allein
aus Wind und Sonne stößt auch in der
Koalition auf Widerspruch
ein breiter Mix hat uns in der
Vergangenheit in Deutschland erfolgreich
gemacht und das sollten wir auch in
Zukunft sofort setzen dann droht kein
Netzausfall und vor allen Dingen bleiben
die Preise für alle stabil für die
Verbraucher und Verbraucher für die
Autofahrer aber auch für die deutsche
Industrie der Minister lässt sich von
solchen Bedenken in der es kaum
beeindrucken Harbeck glaubt fest an die
Grünen Pläne der Koalition und verfolgt
unbeirrt seine Agenda das am Ende
wir alle in unseren verschiedenen Ämtern
nicht daran gemessen werden wie viele
Follower wir haben bei irgendwelchen
sozialen Medien oder wie die
kommentarlage am Tag X vor drei Jahren
war sondern was für ein Werk gesetzt
haben ist Zielen am Ende die Taten der
Vizekanzler heute zu Besuch in Brasilien
es geht um Rohstoffe um Ressourcen und
natürlich um den Regenwald in
Deutschland geht es um eine Revolution
von oben die das Leben der Menschen
verändern wird tiefgreifender vielleicht
als viele ahnen und da wird der Minister
sehr entschlossen